>>> IN OUR BURIED, LEAD, STIES
THAT AREN'T GETTING ENOUGH
ATTENTION, STEVEN MILLER, ONE OF
THE LEAD ARCHITECTS OF THE
BRUTAL SEPARATION AND BORDER
POLICY HAS NOW MADE FIGHTING FOR
THE RIGHTS OF WHITE PEOPLE A
PRIORITY OF A NEW LEGAL GROUP.
MILLER WAGED A LEGAL WAR AGAINST
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
EFFORTS FOR MINORITY FARMERS
THAT HAVE AS A MATTER OF FACT
FOR DECADES FACED INSTITUTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AND AS JESSICA
SCHNEIDER REPORTS, SO FAR STEVEN
MILLER IS WINNING.
>> WE HAVE MULTIPLE TOOLS ACROSS
MULTIPLE FRONTS TO ENSURE WE'RE
PREVENTING TERRORIST.
>> STEVEN MILLER OFTEN THE FACE
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CRACKDOWN
ON IMMIGRATION CONTINUING THE
CONSERVATIVE CRUSADE AFTER
LEAVING HIS POST AS A TOP
ADVISOR.
HE WAS THE PRESIDENT OF A RIGHT
WING ORGANIZATION THAT PLEDGES
IT IS FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
LAWLESS EXECUTIVE ACTIONS AND
THE RADICAL LEFT.
AMERICA FIRST LEGAL SAY IT'S THE
LONG AWAITED ANSWER FOR THE ACLU
AND THEY SUED TO BLOCK TRUMP ERA
POLICIES, AFL FILED A LIT KNEE
OF LAWSUITS CHALLENGING BIDEN
POLICIES THEY VIEW AS ANTI WHITE
AND LIKE THE ACLU, THEY'RE
FLUSHED WITH MILLIONS OF IN NEW
DONATIONS.
>> WHEN DID RACISM AGAINST WHITE
PEOPLE BECOME OKAY?
>> Reporter: FOURTH GENERATION
BLACK FORMER JOHN BOYD WHO SAYS
A LAWSUIT FILED BY MILLER'S
GROUP CAUSED HIM TO LOSE OUT ON
THOUSANDS IN FEDERAL AID.
>> I WANT TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT, NO ONE IS AGAINST
WHITE FARMERS IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: MILLER'S GROUP SUED
SAYING THE FARM DEBT FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM THAT GAVE PREFERENCE TO
NON-WHITE FARMERS VIOLATED CIVIL
LAW AND CONGRESS IS OFFERING
FUNDS TO ALL FARMERS.
>> WHITE FARMERS WERE GETTING
DEBT RELIEF AND GETTING ALL OF
THE DEBT RELIEF FOR ALL THESE
DECADES AND BLACKS AND OTHER
MINORITIES RARELY HAVEN'T BEEN
GETTING DEBT RELIEF.
>> Reporter: THEY CHALLENGED A
COVID RELIEF FUND FOR
RESTAURANTS THAT GAVE FIRST DIBS
TO WOMEN AND MINORITIES.
>> JOE BIDEN PUT WHITE PEOPLE
LAST IN LINE.
>> Reporter: AFC FILED MOST
LAWSUITS IN THE NORTHERN
DECEMBER STRICT OF TEXAS AND
FILING IN FRIENDLY COURTS IS A
TACTIC USED BY LIBERAL AND
CONSERVATIVE GROUPS ALIKE.
NO ONE FROM AFL RESPONDED TO OUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT BUT AFTER A
NEVER ENDING STREAM OF
LITIGATION, ONE OF MY GOALS IS
TO HELP AND INSPIRE AND
COORDINATE A LARGER LEGAL
MOVEMENT ON THE CONSECUTIVE SIDE
OF THE SPECTRUM TO DO THE SAME.
AFL ISN'T JUST RALLYING AGAINST
BIDEN'S POLICIES BUT SOCIAL
ISSUES INCLUDING TRANSGENDER
RIGHTS AND AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
THEY SUED TEXAS A&M FOR HIRING
SOMETHING TEXAS A&MDECEMBER DES.
THEY ARE TAKING THE IDEA OF
REVERSE DISCRIMINATION TOO FAR.
>> IT'S THE USE OF GRIEVANCE
POLITICS THROUGH THE RULE OF LAW
TO TRY TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE OF
COLOR BROADLY BUT IN CERTAIN
POCKETS, BLACK PEOPLE
SPECIFICALLY FROM AREAS OF
OPPORTUNITY.
>> MILLER'S GROUP HAS A NUMBER
OF OTHER LEGAL ACTIONS STILL
PENDING AND PROCLAMATIONS ARE ON
THEIR WEBSITE THAT PROMISE MORE
LEGAL ACTION TO COME.
JAKE?
>> JESSICA SNIDER, THANKS SO
MUCH.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS JIM
CLYBURN FROM SOUTH CAROLINA A
MEMBER OF DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP.
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT IS YOUR
REACTION TO STEVEN MILLER'S NEW
GROUP, THIS LAW FIRM THAT FIGHTS
THAT BLOCK BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAMS THAT ARE TRYING TO REMY
RACIAL AND GENDER DISPARITIES?
>> WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
LOOK, I HAVE BEEN SAYING NOW FOR
MORE THAN A DOZEN YEARS THAT I
DETECT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
AND IN A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
POLLS, ATTEMPTS TO TURN BACK THE
CLOCK.
I JUST FINISHED TODAY A MARKER
IN THE VETERAN'S AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF TWO AFRICAN
AMERICANS WHO CAME HOME AFTER
WORLD WAR II, ONE OF THEM WHILE
IN UNIFORM WAS BLINDED BY A
LOCAL POLICE OFFICER HERE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA.
TOOK HIS BILLY STICK AND PUNCHED
HIS EYES OUT, DENIED ANY KIND OF
ASSISTANCE FROM THE VETERAN'S,
THE SO-CALLED GI BILL.
MATTERS UP IN NEW YORK WAS
ADMITTED TO HARVARD UNIVERSITY
WHO WAS NOT ONLY ALLOWED TO GET
VETERANS BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT WANT TO SET A
PRECEDENCE.
THAT'S WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON
SINCE THE 1940s.
AND WE MOVE TO CORRECT THAT IN
THIS COUNTRY WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT OF '64.
THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF '65.
THE FAIR HOUSING LAW OF '68.
THESE THINGS WERE DONE TO
CORRECT YOUR TRADITIONAL
DISCRIMINATION THAT IS TAKING
PLACE AGAINST BLACK FOLKS.
NOW, WE KNEW, IN FACT, I USED TO
RUN THE SOUTH CAROLINA COME
MISSION FOR FARM WORKERS, THE
VETERANS -- I'M SORRY, THE
AGRICULTURE DEPARTMENT WERE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST BLACK
FARMERS AND THE PICK FOR CASE IS
REPLETE WITH IT AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MOVED TO CORRECT
THAT AND NOW, THEY'RE SAYING
YOU'RE BEING UNFAIR TO WHITE
PEOPLE.
THAT IS WHY TODAY THERE ARE
EIGHT LESS AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
THE SOUTH CAROLINA LEGISLATURE
THAN THERE WERE IN THE PAST
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE THESE LAWS
ARE NOW MAKING IT FAIR GAME TO
DISCRIMINATE SO MILLER KNOWS
WHAT HE'S DOING.
THEY THINK THEY'VE GOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE ON THE SUPREME COURT TO
BACK UP WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND
SO THAT'S WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
I WOULD HOPE THE MEDIA WILL NOT
ALLOW THIS TO GO UNCHECKED.
>> YOU ARE THE CHAIRMAN FOR THE
HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE
CORONAVIRUS CRISIS, WHICH HELD
ITS FINAL HEARING TODAY, WHICH
IS WHY WE BOOKED YOU AND YOU SAY
THE COMMITTEE'S FINAL REPORT
LAYS OUT THAT QUOTE, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S POOR MANAGEMENT
OF RELIEF PROGRAMS LEFT THEM
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
WASTE, FRAUD AND ABUSE AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZED
POLITICS AGAINST PUBLIC HEALTH
ENGAGING IN AN UNPRECEDENTED
CAMPAIGN FOR FEDERAL AGENCIES
FOR PROTECTING AMERICAN'S HEALTH
AND LIVES.
HOW MUCH BLAME FOR THE POOR
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC DO YOU
PUT ON THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AND HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK OUR
COUNTRY'S HEALTH AGENCIES WERE
UNPREPARED AS OPPOSED TO
PURPOSEFULLY FAILING?
>> WELL, THERE IS NO QUESTION
BUT THAT WE WERE UNPREPARED FOR
THIS PANDEMIC.
AND AT OUR HEARING TODAY, OUR
FINAL HEARING, I ASKED DR.
CORBIN WHO AS YOU KNOW IS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN CREDITED
WITH HAVING DONE THE LION'S
SHARE OF THE WORK ON THE MODERNA
VACCINE AND SHE SAID TO ME,
THERE ARE ABOUT 19 OTHER
VARIANTS OUT THERE THAT WE ARE
ILL PREPARED FOR.
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS COMMITTEE
WAS ALL ABOUT.
TRYING TO IDENTIFY WHERE WE HAD
PROBLEMS IN THIS SYSTEM.
AND SO WHEN YOU GET A PANDEMIC
AND VISIT A COMMUNITY THAT IS
ALREADY BEEN DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST, ALREADY BEEN ILL
PREPARED HEALTH WISE, THEN IT
BECOMES A BIG, BIG PROBLEM.
SO IT'S A COMBINATION.
I'M NOT SAYING VETERANS ALL
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION -- NO.
THIS COUNTRY HAS ALLOWED ANY
QUALITY IN HEALTHCARE TO BE A
PART OF IT FOR A LONG, LONG
TIME.
ANY QUALITY IN EDUCATION FOR A
LONG, LONG TIME.
THESE THINGS RUN RAMPED BUT WH